bro i'm now just like going to this
twitter thread about
justin being a [ __ ] yeah wait what
else
what else is there he tells the magazine
back in 2002
when the couple initially parted ways i
felt like she had a couple of
opportunities to just sort of stick up
for me and she didn't which is fine but
at that time you know i fought back
and that's the way i fought back i used
my mind i came up with a song man you're
so cool
he bro a diss track for on a woman
that's crazy
that's crazy
[Laughter]
damn 2007. he gets on some awards show
and he tells brittany to stop drinking
and not to get sloppy
holy [ __ ] the [ __ ] gall on this guy
man
let this one play luke mock award
for right now and if someone doesn't
send me my real brit
in the mail um
there will be hell to pay thank you very
much for this
i i'm very flattered uh i'm actually on
tour so i couldn't be there
everyone have a great night um stop
drinking you know who you are
i'm speaking to you stop drinking you're
gonna get sloppy
uh okay is gonna say something bad about
you
um you guys have fun tonight thank you
very much for this
whoa what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] that wasn't that long ago
that was in 2000 man you know if
but if it wasn't for justin again her
this this is a strong-willed woman who
just
you know exactly i mean this is just
restitution for brittany's brother man
it's tough out there for dudes so
awesome
yeah man can keep we do we have any more
clips or
is there anything else good in this holy
[ __ ]
after brittany went through her
breakdown justin oh it's a song it's a
song we can't do it
okay okay explain this
world has long been full of madonna
wannabes
and i might have even dated a couple
but there is like this is only what [ __ ]
is the worst
so right now it is one of the true
thrills and privileges of my life to
stand on this stage
and induct madonna into the rock and
roll hall of fame like when it comes to
the audience and you just see another
old dude go
yeah it's like oh my god
oh yeah bro play this 2009
i'd like to think that at first hitler
dates a popular female singer
publicly they'll claim to be virgins but
privately
he hid it
[Applause]
nice nice 2009
2009 why are we still talking about her
virginity
nice snl and how she lost it is [ __ ]
weird
yeah it's just like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
man this is this is crazy it's pretty
alarming when you see all this [ __ ]
back to back right yeah you just you
just kind of highlight like
i mean when you're a punching bag for
like
20 years it has to make you go a little
bit
and i mean i'm not calling i mean she i
don't know i'm not calling her crazy
she's definitely a little off right you
look at her instagram post and you're
like something's not right here
but i think i think i'd be off if i was
in her scenario as well i think so too
that's what i'm saying like
it's just it's man we've laughed at her
posts on this
podcast yeah no we're completely guilty
of her before
yeah but it's just i don't know it's
wild when you see it like this is like
oh my god she's
i didn't know idea you know i wasn't
part of this
i think that's the problem though i
think that
you know from that tabloid era like they
just
spun one message and that [ __ ] stuck
with you like you just kind of thought
oh yeah that's that's got to be it's got
to be true right
you know she shaved her head like she's
[ __ ] nuts right yeah
and uh i mean it just it just sucks
like it and it's so
when you think about it it's [ __ ]
pathetic like how many [ __ ]
supposed comedy writers and show writers
and
all of this [ __ ] just were like oh what
if we did a britney joke
yeah damn this whole game
you guys have been a hack for like how
long now
that [ __ ] is wild man oh my god yeah
dude let's do like a throwback joke
about you
you [ __ ] britney spears when you guys
were dating in the 90s remember that
when she claimed she was a virgin should
we throw it back to that
that'd be cool oh bogus claimed that she
was a virgin when we all know you
[ __ ] hit it dog
right lake right you're freaking lazy
freaking freaking freaking you freaking
freaky
and britney's [ __ ] puss right britney
sucked you
off dog
just been drinking women respect or
juice for like the last 30 minutes but
it was you know it was [ __ ] up all
that's [ __ ] up
yeah that being said though like the
free britney people like standing
outside of the courtroom it's like oh my
god
find a [ __ ] better cause you know
what i'm saying it's been an
all day outside of the like it's what
they're gonna do they're gonna come get
you they're gonna come get you
i'm on their side i'm saying i free
britney like this shit's [ __ ] up she
should not first of all the whole
conservatorship is
thing is wild as [ __ ] but do you think
anything
would have been different if they didn't
do that
yes what do you think the whole thing
came from the podcast episode that those
girls
i don't think the people standing
outside the courtroom with signs that
say free britney did
anything but i might be wrong it's like
she no matter how i mean yeah we've
talked about it for the last 30 minutes
and she's in a really messed up place
but she's still super rich and lives in
a giant mansion and
is a celebrity yeah yeah
i mean she definitely has her career to
stand on
regardless of the shitty people yeah um
that's i mean i think that's the
craziest part from all this is it's
i would have to imagine a conservator is
probably redefined in this whole
scenario
especially if you're yeah i mean
or like i wonder it's such a unique case
of someone that's young
that was totally mentally yeah
it's stable and super rich it's like it
has to be one of the only scenarios of
somebody losing their estate to someone
else when they're like made all the
money themselves and they're young
that piece of [ __ ] lawyer that was like
you know she was speaking about how
conservatorship works
yeah and she's like i've never seen a
conservatorship successfully
re you know revoked and then she and
it's like oh after filming this she goes
back and joins
you know jamie's jamie spears legal team
it's like
you just like spoke in a documentary
covering how [ __ ] up this scenario is
like
you don't have any bit of decency to be
like you know i get you got to feed your
family and [ __ ] but you
literally just did a documentary where
they're highlighting this issue
yeah and you go you know [ __ ] it
i'm still trying to get paid from that
exact same conservative [ __ ] baby
[Laughter]
she's like yeah i don't want to say
anything to [ __ ] this case up because
that is my new portion
so part of that is mine okay so we're
just gonna we're gonna keep it vague
and keep it real chilled yeah i don't
know man